this is Boeing's 737 max and this is its
rival the Airbus a320neo these planes
are at the center of the biggest rivalry
in the aviation industry they're both
competing for the same market and are
mostly used on relatively short trips
like Boston to Miami or London to Madrid
now also thanks to the a320neo Airbus
has had a solid year the airliner has
established itself as a best seller
since it first made its commercial
flight in 2016
Boeing on the other hand has had a very
rough year the 737 max which started
flying commercially in 2017 was supposed
to strengthen Boeing's position as the
world's largest plane maker instead it
became a symbol of one of the worst
crises in the company's history what
does this all mean for the two companies
that secure 99% of the world's large
plane orders it's really you know to all
competitors battling it out in the ring
and they say there's no there's no room
in this ring for anybody else
this chart shows deliveries for Boeing
and Airbus since the start of 2019
you'll see Boeing's total deliveries
start to fall after the March grounding
of 737 max jets and as it stands now
there's virtually no way Boeing can
deliver more planes and Airbus this year
but Airbus might not hold the top spot
for long
this will bounce back and forward
between the two companies depending on
on the product they're selling on the
number and the number of analyzes if
they can get on board it really is
something you can sort of watch this go
back and forward like a tide coming out
and tide going in so what's behind this
latest power shift in the aviation world
what's happening with boeing 737 max is
a good place to start the crash into the
ocean a lion air Boeing 737 a
devastating scene tonight an Ethiopian
Airlines jet with 157 people on board
has crashed after two deadly crashes and
five-month
boeing 737 max became the subject of
international investigations public
scrutiny a flood of lawsuits and some
high-profile shakeups in the company's
leadership we're going to be issuing an
emergency order of prohibition to ground
all flights of the 737 max 8 and the 737
max 9 the max situation has raised
concerns about whether boeing has done
enough to make sure its planes are safe
to fly safety is our responsibility we
own it and the work of our team will
make the 737 max one of the safest
airplanes ever to fly the company's
business has taken a hit many of those
737 maxes are just sitting in Boeing
facilities and other storage areas
around the world as of October the max
crisis had already cost Boeing nine
billion dollars and wiped more than 40
billion off its market value as a
situation drags on Boeing has tried to
boost confidence reiterating the safety
is its top priority in a September press
release CEO Dennis Muhlenberg said that
ensuring the safety of the flying public
pilots and crew is Boeing's top priority
as they work to return the 737 max to
service Muhlenberg was stripped of his
chairmanship on October 11 but he is
still the CEO so does this mean Airbus
is benefiting from the 737 Max's woes
not necessarily flying an airliner is
not like going down to your show your
local car showroom and saying I don't
like a Ford I'll pop down to Chevy and
see what they've got you really are in a
in a list you're in a queue that's got a
line that's gonna stretch back to maybe
even three years if it's a really
popular airplane even without the max
situation Airbus was already on track to
overtake Boeing's deliveries now it just
appears to be happening a little sooner
than expect
and that's thanks in part to the a320neo
airbus has gone from producing 50 a
month in 2017 to 60 the next year with
the CEO saying demand could possibly
support more than 70 a month in the near
future but it's not all about these two
planes Airbus and Boeing make other
models and they're facing challenges
there too
Airbus is phasing out its a380 model
which hasn't been selling well but
production on it was already so low it's
not having much of an impact on the
company's overall output boeing has
repeatedly had to push back the first
test flight of its triple 7x due to
production problems in a september press
release boeing said it doesn't expect
further delays in quote we remain fully
focused on safety as our highest
priority as we subject the triple 7x to
a rigorous test program prior to first
flight not that delays on new planes are
unusual both boeing and airbus have
faced production problems before it's
just really bad timing for boeing to
take on another set of issues right now
the company is still trying to get at
737 max back in the air after more than
seven months on the ground and that's
just the planes the aviation Giants have
a lot of other factors to think about
too like geopolitics and tariffs in
October the WTO said the u.s. can
slapped 7.5 billion dollars worth of
tariffs on EU produced goods because of
the subsidies Airbus gets from the EU in
a statement Airbus said the only way to
prevent negative effects of the tariffs
is for the US and EU to negotiate a
settlement
there's also brakes it oil prices trade
wars regulation and of course
competition supported by the Chinese
government Chinese made planes may soon
hit the market though it could take
years for the Chinese company known as
Commack to scale up production the
competition from China is maybe 10 years
away from becoming significant as air
travel continues to rise and both
companies anticipate growth in the
coming years whatever happens with these
planes will
tell millions of people move across the
world